se trata de hacerlo que fueron liberados
por razones humanitarias es lo que se
sabe y un anuncio que hizo el mismo
presidente Manuel su cuenta de Twitter
quien pues daba aplauso a esta
Liberación y explicó que el país
continuará luchando para que los demás
franceses retenidos en Irán puedan
regresar a sus hogares de estos
franceses que se sabe bueno de 37 años
fue arrestado en 2020 en el Noroeste del
país acusado de espionaje condenado a
ocho años y ocho meses de prisión y sin
embargo había ganado su caso en
apelación a comienzos de este año pero
nunca fue liberado Y desde entonces
estaba en una huelga total de hambre
mientras que felón quien también tiene
la nacionalidad irlandesa Pues él fue
arrestado en octubre del año pasado
sobre la misma época en la que una ola
de arrestos durante las protestas tras
la muerte de marsa Mini esta joven que
fue muerta por la policía iraní por no
portar bien el velo islámico él estaba
allí diciendo que trabajaba como
consultor de una empresa de turismo fue
arrestado condenado a seis años de
prisión y desde entonces también a pesar
de sus quebrantos de salud también
estaba en una huelga de hambre así que
ambos franceses Pues antes de abordar el
avión que fue dispuesto por ellos por el
gobierno francés para traerlos aquí a
París Fueron vistoso por un médico es
muy probable que a su llegada tengan que
ser hospitalizados y se espera la
llegada de ambos aquí a París sobre las
ocho de la noche y por ahora Pues en
Irán se sabe que todavía hay cuatro
franceses que se encuentran en las
prisiones de ese país